[Music]
don't you know that words and actions
have consequences
if you do something wrong you're gonna
pay for it
so some call it cancel culture but i
call it that's what joe ass
gets
[Music]
this is curtis sliwa a conservative
radio personality who's running for
mayor of new york
last month he marked the easing of face
mask guidelines by holding a mask
burning event
where he burned his hand and i gotta say
that's what joe ass gets burning things
on a mass level is never the sign of you
being on the right side of history
books witches nwa cds none of them were
burned by good people
sliwa did this publicity stunt to win
votes from conservatives and that is so
pitiful
he thought he looked like this
but really he looked like this fire
fire fire fire
a photo from the event shows sliwa
submerging his hand in a bucket of water
as he continued to burn masks which
explains his campaign slogan
burn me once because i'm a idiot
speaking of getting burned a group of
people in a boat in moses lake
washington
recently harassed the occupants of
another boat that was flying a gay
pride flag the harasser circled the boat
that was flying the flag
gave them the finger and shouted slurs
and then right after they did that their
boat
blew up and you know what that's what
joe ass gets
what in the 80s movie bullying were you
thinking
don't you know that bodies of water hate
bigots remember when all those maga
boats sank in texas
good times that boat catching on fire
was crazy
even crazier after their boat blew up
those terrible people were saved by the
people they were just harassing and they
didn't even thank them
now how trifling can you be being nice
costs nothing but being hateful
don't cost your ass a boat meanwhile
tennis superstar naomi osaka announced
recently that
she would skip all press interviews
leading up to the french open in order
to protect her mental health but
the french open didn't like that and
they said if you don't do interviews
we're gonna find you fifteen
thousand dollars and naomi said okay and
she paid the fine
then the french open said uh if you
don't do interviews we're gonna make you
drop out and naomi said
okay and she dropped out and that's what
your ass
gets french open you could have had a
bad [ __ ] but
instead of protecting her health you
would rather threaten and find her
so she said au revoir felicia and naomi
is getting support from all over
including nike steph curry martina
navratilova
serena williams and venus williams in
fact
here's what venus had to say about
dealing with the stress of media
interviews
for me personally how i quote how i deal
with it was that i know every single
person asked me a question
can't play as well as i can and never
will so
no matter what you say or what you write
you'll never let it candle to me
so that's how i deal with it um but each
person deals with it differently
damn is it dark in here is that
the shade that venus was giving look
naomi osaka is there to play tennis
anything else
should be volunteer only can you imagine
going to your job
working a full shift and then having to
answer snarky ass questions from someone
who can't even do your job
the french open should be relieved that
a queen like naomi would even grace them
with her presence now
let's not forget this is tennis tennis
women like venus and serena williams and
naomi osaka took
tennis from this
to this
[Music]
so put some respect on naomi's name take
two seats back and collect the money she
is generating for you
instead of threatening and finding
someone who just wants to play the game
they love
and protect their mental health lastly
it was reported that donald trump's blog
from the desk of donald j
trump has been permanently shut down
after only a month due to low readership
and i got to say that's what joe ass
gets
your followers can barely read a whole
tweet you start throwing paragraphs at
them and they're definitely going to
short circuit
and who has a blog these days is it 2002
what was he typing it on his dell
computer wearing highlights in his hair
while downloading lose yourself on
napster
for those of you who are younger please
google those references
so call it cancel culture or whatever
you want but the fact is
if you act like an idiot and hurt other
people in the process something bad
is going to happen to you and when it
does well
that's what your ass gets
you